in this video we'll talk about zero
Dharma pigmentosum
zero gamma pigmentosum is a very rare
skin disorder where people are highly
sensitive to UV damage and they don't
have a good repair system the risk genes
include xpa xpc D G and F
so all of these genes are actually
involved in the UV repair system so
these are component of nucleotide repair
system
so in this particular disease the person
get high exposure from the UV rays there
could be DNA damage due to the UV rays
but it is not repaired in an optimal
fashion and that lead to many
complications and most worst case
scenario is skin cancer
when genetics is concerned this
particular disease is autosomal
recessive in nature that means there is
a 25 percent of chance that in the Next
Generation somebody would be affected by
this disease
symptoms include thinning of the skin
visible broken blood vessels dry and red
eye potential skin cancers dark and
light patches of pigmented skin then
sensitive towards light especially
sunlight
so in order to understand the biology
behind this disease we have to
understand the process of nucleotide
excision repair in bit more details
nucleotide excision repair protects our
DNA from UV damage when there is a UV
damage it forms
this kind of dimers so thymine thymine
dimer is a common lesion caused by UV
radiation and this kind of you thymine
dimer can distort the DNA architecture
and this has to be repaired and there
are set of proteins that can sit and
repair this kind of damages caused by
harmful UV radiation
and that system is known as nucleotide
excision repair system this particular
system is well conserved from bacteria
to human so let us understand this
process in bacteria first for Simplicity
and then we'll extrapolate to Human
so imagine there is a dimer in this so
the dimer is recognized by uvr ape and
uvrb protein eventually the DNA lesion
uh
is kind of recognized by this set of
protein Machinery uvr loads uvrb in the
recognition site
eventually
ATP is hydrolyzed
and uvrb cause a bend in the DNA then
uvrc gets loaded eventually
it creates Nick in the DNA and there is
a helicase uvrd
which leads to
chopping off that portion of the Strand
this is known as the excision
so after excision a portion of the
Strand is basically now
single stranded and open hydroxyl end is
produced there so in that case specific
polymerase polymerizes this particular
damage and at the end Gap is sealed by a
ligase enzyme so this General proforma
that means excision followed by the
repair is pretty similar in human and
bacteria
so this was in bacteria in human these
uvr a proteins are actually known as xpc
xpd
xpd creates a bubble around the
particular lesion
then there are also RPA proteins which
hold the strands there are ercc one xpf
protein that creates the Nick and there
are xpg proteins so all of these
proteins are analogous to the uh E coli
protein anyway this particular kind of
repair system works hand in hand with
the transcription machinery so
transcription actually the RNA
polymerase recruit this kind of
this kind of DNA repair Machinery to the
site of lesion and the lesion is
repaired and transcription can be
resumed so that is why this particular
transcription uh this couple
transcription coupled repair is very
important for the disease etiology now
if this particular repair is abrogated
then there are high risk of accumulating
mutations there are also risk of
changing gene expression modulation
because these repair system goes hand in
hand with transcription and that leads
to many complications and the most worst
is the cancer
so
the treatment option includes protective
gears like UV protective jackets caps
sunglasses and sunscreen and the
prevention is better than cure so
staying at home in a protective
environment where you are not exposed to
UV light is the solution
right now there is no definitive cure
for this disease managing this
particular disease with proper treatment
and Care is the only option I hope this
was useful if you like this video give
it a big thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe you can get more
notes and flashcards in our Facebook
page and Instagram you can support our
Channel using super thanks see you in
next video